each weapon has two qualities
and they share one quality among them
so the vulcan's individual quality
is slightness and quickness
it's second quality is sticky
it sticks
joe's individual quality
is heavy not like great
heavy
heavy and the shared quality
sticky sticky
so
not sticky not heavy
not sticky not quick
not lying
right
can you see that
you know what tammy was always working
it's more of a ballistic takedown okay
it's not a pain compliance meaning i
don't hit you so hard you want to quit
or i hit you so hard you can't think
anymore it's a ballistic takedown it's a
ballistic throw
okay so when you get to that last move
some of you don't have that angle
you're going here right into his foot
this this angle you have to get this
[Music]
so it has to do with how you turn
and how you do a umiyashi if you bring
your center of gravity with you
with that foot you can only go straight
but if you start to first shift you see
there'll be a hip rotation boom and i
can get the turn
so somebody with the leg is so in the
way even
that you can't go forward because his
leg is there i can't go forward his legs
there
but if you shift first then your hips
rotate boom you can cut a curve around
that
angle
so your footwork is off
oh i have to shift and then
hit this angle but this stays over my
head
then next thing don't let your uk stay
there
because that's bad for them okay
you can go slow but you go full
so that part probably
is a little pain compliance but it's
four k
not for an attacker okay so
he's there i just drilled it
he becomes more responsive right
[Music]
he better be responsive
okay let's go
all right keep keep your form you don't
have to go fast but your form should be
alive
[Music]
he stepped in
good if you guys
that's too early don't practice
cowardice
too early get up take this one move the
weapon
take it
you've left me with your arms
what what does heavy heavy means
down down means mid-foot vectoring
and a lowering of my center okay
so i don't want to do the job
and my center never lowers let's make
that first
mistake my center's never low come on
see i just keep standing straight up no
knee bend
it's fat but it's not heavy
instead my center will change height
go ahead and
i'm here not after
nothing
mid-foot vector it almost is impossible
to have midfoot vectoring
without the knees look bending
and the center lowering okay so
when i keep my center high i can't put
the joe
on the mid foot so if i drop the
if i lower the weapon right now it's a
head
you put it on the midfoot i have to
do that so in the lower the center
i can get the midfoot vector
here boom boom
here
and then for tactical consideration
my tokyo does not attack his vulcan
or his hands it attacks his balance
so my movement is
boom
we go on my movement
his balance
i'm always pushing through
the center
and that the more i do that the more
curfew i have
the more i can cultivate okay